fifty years after ireland voted to join
the european community citizens from
across the continent gathered in dublin
to finalise their ideas for tomorrow's
eu
it was the last meeting of this european
citizens panel or part of the conference
on the future of europe
there was a show of solidarity with the
people of ukraine before participants
put forward recommendations on the
labour market and how to balance growth
and equality
we recommend minimum wages with a
perspective into some sort of minimum
net income
provided for all european citizens it's
about social justice protecting those
with the poor wages no
education poor skills
meanwhile panelists looked at how to
make europe's economy more sustainable
we want to incentivize environmentally
friendly production in the form of
possibly tax benefits for companies that
are producing an environmentally
friendly way with the online world ever
more central to our lives participants
discussed how to guarantee everyone in
the eu has access to digital tools tech
and skills they put forward ways to
protect users privacy and ensure good
practice from tech giants we're thinking
about creating a pan-european agency
that will be monitoring this and also be
responsible for sanctioning and
certifying sites and companies and being
our voice against these big companies
citizens also recommended stronger
cultural and linguistic exchanges across
the eu and measures to promote sports
and physical activity
20 panel representatives will champion
the recommendations in march at the
conference plenary in the european
parliament and strasbourg
the work of camilla owen vasco and their
fellow citizens will feed into a final
report which eu institutions will have
to follow up on
[Music]
you